to Kenya now where followers of a
doomsday cult have appeared in court
they're charged with attempted suicide
which is a criminal offense in Kenya
around 65 people rescued from the
shakahola forest say they're on hunger
strike while their leader faces various
charges Paul McKenzie their leader is
accused of ordering his followers to
starve themselves to death to in his
words meet Jesus let's bring in Al
jazeera's Catherine soy in Nairobi so
this is the case Catherine of survivors
of Paul McKenzie's cult who are refusing
to eat the prosecutor wants them charged
with attempted suicide because that's
illegal in Kenya of course what's the
court decided then
yes the court has ruled on that uh
situation and it the session itself took
about two hours with human rights
lawyers and the prosecutor uh making
their submissions before the court and
they all agreed that these survivors do
not need to be in police Cassidy
currently they have been in police
custody so they will be taken back to
the rescue center but one of the
survivors has opted not to go back to
the rescue center so he is going to be
in a police remand and that her case
will be reviewed in next 20 uh two weeks
so
um the judge as I said the magistrates
as I said ruled and he said that the
survivors will be taken through mental
assessment Sarah mental assessments and
individual reports will be given to the
court the the magistrate also said that
the court is to supervise the welfare of
the survivors and this review will be
done at the end of the month but the
good news as well is that the survivors
have agreed to eat and cooperate with
the councilors and of these other people
who are taking care of the survivors at
that centers that's a rescue center so
they've agreed to end their hunger
strike the survivors which as you say is
good news this is a case in a story
that's fascinated and shocked I think is
a better word people in Kenya and Beyond
what's the latest on investigations in
shakalala forest and the relatives were
still waiting for news of their loved
ones
while people are following this case
very very closely it's a shocking case
so people are really been debating about
it as well and in shakahola
investigations are still going on uh the
bodies are being exhumed as we speak as
so far uh the death toll stands at
318 buddies recovered and Counting
um we know that uh post-mortem still
going on DNA testing still going on
um you know some we haven't seen many
people in recent days being rescued from
that run but then we've been talking to
um some of the relatives of those who
are missing who are saying that right
now they just want to make sure and they
want to see the bodies of their loved
ones they want to take their remains
home so that they can give them a decent
burial Catherine thank you so much for
that Catherine soy reporting their life
from Nairobi